everything must be perfect we were told
in the lead up to today and so the March
was delayed by a few hours so they could
wait for the clouds to clear nothing is
allowed to rain on Kim Jong Un's parade
when it's did begin mid-afternoon it did
so as they wanted in bright sunshine
thousands of soldiers filling the
enormous Kim il-sung's square in the
centre Pyongyang
then came Kim jong-un on a balcony
overlooking them all above portraits of
his father Kim jong-il and his
grandfather president kim ill sung
humanik clapping from the onlooking
crowd
teach your muscles she's run heavy man
and you go to 3-under Jesu are we done
today our party our revolutionary armed
power can deal with any form of war
America wants and I declare confidently
that we are ready to safeguard the blue
sky of our homeland and the Peace of our
people with strong determination the
goose-stepping soldiers kept coming and
coming
the must have been tens of thousands of
them
there is national conscription in North
Korea the military here is a way of life
it's the only way the country knows how
to feel safe military is strength as a
leader within this country thousands of
civilians slowly replaced the soldiers
robotically waving pink and red plastic
flowers
they lined a route for the serious
military hardware to parade in front of
muscle
today was about a display of utter
devotion to a leader North Korea is the
most secretive state in the world but
when it does open its doors it does it
like this Alastor bundle Sky News in
Pyongyang North Korea